good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Barnes & Noble
tonight's book selling sickness by Ray
Moynihan and Alan Cassell's discusses
how the world's pharmaceutical industry
is turning us all into patients Ray
Moynihan is with us he's one of the
world's leading health writers who
specializes in the business of medicine
he's a visiting editor and contributor
of the British Medical Journal and his
articles have appeared in the New
England Journal of Medicine and The
Lancet he was awarded a Harkness
fellowship at Harvard University ladies
and gentleman please welcome ray
Moynihan and selling sickness thank you
thank you very much thanks for coming
out I know it's the middle of your
holiday and it's very hot so thanks for
making the effort for me it's a lovely
break because it's actually winter in
Sydney so this is I'm really enjoying
the humidity I'm sorry to say I want to
I want to thank some people first of all
I want to thank nation books in Avalon
for for publishing this book and Barnes
& Noble for putting this on and all the
people who contributed to making this
book work and one of them a key one is
actually dr. Leonor Tifa who's here and
you'll probably hear from later and she
she has run a fairly successful campaign
critiquing some of the marketing that
I'm going to talk about tonight in
relation to the area specifically of
sexual dysfunction female sexual
dysfunction and it was Leonor who came
up with the wonderful line not tonight
dear the dog ate my testosterone patch
and if only I had that humor I would I'd
be able to give up give up work I think
and but but anyway let's let's talk
about this subject it's quite a serious
one what I want to do tonight is I want
to lay out the problem that the book
explains I want to give you some
examples of the problem and I want to
briefly talk about some of the solutions
that I have thought about and then I
want some robust and vigorous discussion
because I'm hoping that we don't all
agree I'm hoping that there's some
controversy here and some difference of
opinion I'm a bit worried you look like
a very sympathetic audience but but
anyway let's hope that someone from
Pfizer here and if you are if you are
welcome so so what is the problem that
selling sickness identifies essentially
there's three themes to this problem the
first is that condition by condition the
boundaries of illness are being
inexorably widened high blood pressure
high cholesterol bone mineral density
type 2 diabetes sexual dysfunction
mental illness across the board the
boundaries the official boundaries set
by the official panels are being
inexorably widened so that all of us
sooner or later end up with multiple
illnesses not just one multiple and
increasingly it's the healthy who are
targeted that's the first problem the
second part of the problem is the drug
company marketing strategies
now essentially target the healthy more
and more and there is a concerted
attempt to turn the ordinary ups and
downs of daily life into the signs and
symptoms of medical illness and I will
talk about specific examples and the
book by the way is full of very well
documented and very well checked facts
because when I talk like this you must
think what a raving lunatic this guy is
he's just a journalist anyway and you'd
be right but but in fact I've drawn on
some very serious scientific evidence
and some very heavy-duty sources around
the world for this so we've got two
problems the widening of the boundaries
and drug company marketing strategies
essentially targeting the healthy trying
to turn the common ailments of ordinary
life into medical conditions and the
third problem is that we have
a medical profession a medical
establishment essentially corrupted by
its relationship with the drug industry
and this is something I think all of you
are probably very familiar with now in
this country particular you have at
every layer of the medical establishment
drug company money lubricating the
machinery the doctors the specialists
the key opinion leaders the patient
groups even medical journalists are
accepting money from drug companies to
do their reporting even the regulator's
as you as you probably know half of the
drug review work that the FDA does is
funded directly by drug companies more
than half and of course the FDA has its
own crisis of legitimacy as a result as
many of you will know so there the three
prongs really of the problem the
widening of the boundaries the marketing
strategy is targeted at the healthy and
the entanglement between the people we
thought were independent and the
pharmaceutical industry and look don't
take my word for this listen to a guy
called Vince Perry who's quoted in the
introduction in the prologue to this
book Vince Perry is a former advertising
executive in this town who is now a
specialist in what's called condition
branding not branding drugs not not
designing brands like viagra or prozac
or prilosec or or claritin or all those
brands branding conditions
that's what Vince Perry and his
colleagues and his peers are now doing
for the drug industry they are branding
conditions they are helping define
conditions in order to match those
conditions with their products and again
don't take my word for it you can read
it it's well referenced Vince Perry has
written publicly about this and has
spoken publicly in a documentary that I
helped make based on this book one of
the documentaries that's being made
based on this book
so Vince is a conditioned Brander and
he's talked publicly about the
strategies for quote fostering the
creation of diseases and dysfunctions
and disorders and so this is this is
going on and this town is really the
epicenter of that and and I think we're
in Manhattan today we are that this town
is the center of the global PR houses
that work with Big Pharma and and that
influenced the way we are now thinking
about illness and what happens in
Manhattan affects the rest of the world
as you know and and that brings lots of
positive things to the world but
sometimes there's the odd problem too so
let me give before what I want to do is
give you three examples three conditions
that I think have been broadened and and
sold and sold to you by the drug
industry and appropriately before I do
that if you can indulge me I'd like to
briefly read from the book I've actually
launched this book in many cities within
Australia small unknown country down in
the Pacific somewhere I know most of you
don't really care about about Australia
but but it was my home my home and still
is in some ways when I've launched books
there I haven't read because we have a
great tradition of anti-intellectualism
in Australia but but it but but seeing
as I'm in Manhattan if you can indulge
me I'm going to read very briefly
because I don't want you to nod off I
want to keep you keep you awake for at
least the next half hour but I think
there's a couple of key points here that
that that I can't articulate any better
than I have here so let me just briefly
read from the prologue from selling
sickness and then I want to give you
three quite juicy examples of selling
sickness there are many different
promotional strategies used in the
selling of sickness but the common
factor among them all is the marketing
of fear the fear of heart attacks was
used to sell women the idea that the
menopause is a condition requiring
hormone replacement the fear of youth
suicide is
used to sell parents the idea that even
mild depression might be treated with
powerful drugs the fear of an early
death is used to sell high cholesterol
as something automatically requiring a
prescription yet ironically the
much-hyped medicines sometimes cause the
very harm they are supposed to prevent
long term hormone replacement therapy
increases the risk of heart attacks for
women while antidepressants appear to
increase the risk of suicidal thinking
among the young at least one of the
blockbuster cholesterol-lowering drugs
has been withdrawn from the market
because it was implicated in causing
deaths not preventing them in one of the
most horrific cases of all a drug sold
as helping with common bowel problems
called irritable bowel syndrome led to
constipation so severe for some people
they simply died yet in this case as in
so many others the official government
regulators somehow seemed more
interested in protecting drug company
profits than the public's health the
pharmaceutical industry and its
supporters defend their marketing
campaigns as raising awareness about
misunderstood diseases and providing
quality information about the latest
medicines company executives talk of
empowering consumers with advertising
and they're paid celebrities are said to
educate the public about health
conditions by glossy magazine articles
on TV talk shows certainly there are
some valuable examples of industry
sponsored efforts to D stigmatize a
health problem or stimulate much-needed
action as has occurred in the area of
hiv-aids
it in other cases these campaigns are
not educational at all but plain old
promotion skewing our understanding of
the causes of human illness and
distorting our knowledge of their
remedies playing up the benefits of
drugs and playing down their harms and
costs and finally a loosening of
advertising regulations in the late
1990s in the US has delivered an
unprecedented onslaught of drug
marketing targeted at ordinary people
who now watch an average of 10
or more advertisements every day
likewise viewers in New Zealand are
subject to this sort of promotion New
Zealand's also a small country down in
the south
well elsewhere in the world the industry
is fighting relentlessly for similar
deregulation for the supporters this
marketing is a valuable service for the
critics it is putting disease at the
center of human life it's pushing the
genuinely ill towards a limited range of
the most expensive drug solutions and
it's making tens of millions of the
healthy start to fear that their bodies
are broken dysfunctional deficient and
decaying this disease mongering is an
assault on our collective soul by those
seeking to profit from our fear it's no
dark conspiracy simply daylight robbery
sorry I got a bit serious and earnest
there but but I think this is a serious
threat to public health I think that the
disease mongering that is now an
integral part of the pharmaceutical
company's marketing strategies is a
threat to public health and I think it's
time we did something about it and I've
come to that conclusion because I'm a
journalist writing about this stuff and
health care journalists are among the
most targeted of all because we are the
ones who are supposed to explain all
this stuff to you and so that so the
pressure and the influence and the
promotional intensity that that hits
healthcare journalists is extraordinary
which is why it's it's been relatively
easy for me to see this story and to
write about it so let's have some
examples because you're all saying this
is a load of rubbish and we want some
evidence so so let's have some evidence
the first one I want to talk about is
social anxiety disorder social anxiety
disorder is in fact a legitimate
psychiatric disorder and like most of
the conditions in this book there are 10
conditions there are ten chapters in
this book like most of them they are
legitimate medical conditions no
question the point is about where you
draw the boundary
where you draw the lines who's in and
who's out and so let's talk about social
anxiety disorder a lot of reputable
experts suggest that perhaps 1% of
people may suffer from this psychiatric
condition perhaps one percent when
GlaxoSmithKline tried to attempted to
start marketing this condition in the
late 1990s they suggested that not 1%
but 13 percent of people suffered from
this problem and there was part of the
campaign's suggested explicitly asserted
that 1 in 8 Americans suffer from social
anxiety disorder I mean do the math in
this room and and and I must say
Americans don't often strike me as the
most shy people in the world so so what
we've seen with social anxiety disorder
I'll talk briefly in some detail about
what happened I think we've seen an
attempt to blur the boundaries between
ordinary shyness and a psychiatric
condition and I think the strong
evidence of this in the marketing
campaign so let's go back to 1998 when
GlaxoSmithKline was had another name
then but it ultimately became
GlaxoSmithKline an anglo-american drug
company it was looking for new markets
for its drug called paxil and so one way
to get new markets is to is to is to
have your drug approved for a new
condition and so it wanted to get its
drug approved for social anxiety
disorder and so what did it do in order
to do that it hired a PR company it
hired I mean I call male fashion I find
it odd that a drug company would hire a
PR house to help do that but that's the
modern world of marketing and medicine
and so Conan Wolford or a PR house a
very sophisticated way and they sit not
far down on this island somewhere and
and
were hired by was SmithKline Beecham at
that time to to position social anxiety
disorder as a serious and credible
problem and so what did Cohn and Wolff
do well one of the first things they did
was create a fake grassroots campaign
and in the business a fake grassroots
campaign is called astroturf thing an
astroturf thing is now a common tool in
the PR houses toolkit correct me if I'm
wrong if there's anyone here from Conan
wolf or from the PR industry please
correct me if I'm wrong but my
understanding is that creating what
looked like grassroots campaigns is now
a common strategy of the big
sophisticated corporate PR houses and so
that's exactly what happened with the
selling of social anxiety disorder there
was a so-called social anxiety disorder
coalition created that included patient
groups and medical groups all
orchestrated by the PR house and the
drug company paying the bills but you
didn't see that what you all saw was the
the coalition's advertising which was on
bus shelters in newspapers and elsewhere
and the whole point was to link this new
branded condition social anxiety
disorder with paxil that was the point
was to was to link social anxiety
disorder with paxil and that's what
happened and it was such a successful
campaign that Cohn and Wolf very proudly
talked publicly about how successful it
was and so you can go to a website and
find out about this and in fact it was
so successful I need to get closer to
the mic and that will go to where what I
just said that's fine okay so I'm closer
to the mark now I'm sorry about that
I hope you've you've heard some of those
things I've just said or perhaps it's
better that you didn't hear them
particularly the lawyers that
GlaxoSmithKline I'm talking to okay so
um so where were we so we're talking
about social anxiety disorder and and
and the fact that conan wolf won a PR
industry award for their work and and
that's the way medicine works these days
and so it's this is all you know please
III I'm desperate for criticism I'm
desperate for people to correct what I'm
saying
because sometimes I worry that I'm
actually right you know I I I'm very
worried we'll take questions later I'll
just finish a finish first sometimes I
worry that I'm right and and and and
just as a quick aside the book has been
out for a month or more in Australia not
one line not one fact not one assertion
has been challenged by anyone the
pharmaceutical industry for some reason
have lost their tongue which is odd give
given the given the size of the
promotional budgets so so so just to
finish off social anxiety disorder we
had a very successful marketing campaign
that was about trying to change the way
you all think about shyness about a fear
of public speaking and all of those
things and again let me stress at some
level we have a genuine psychiatric
condition and a small cohort of people
who can benefit from that label and from
medication let's be absolutely clear
about that for the record and the book
is very clear about that
but what you have is an attempt to
suggest that a far wider cohort of
people are sick and in need of some sort
of therapy so that's social anxiety
disorder and just to give another
example from that campaign the use of
celebrities was integral to that
campaign and and is integral to many
campaigns
and so in that campaign you had a
football I don't know if any of you know
him a guy called Ricky Williams he's
from Miami I'm getting a couple of nods
that's great so sir Ricky Williams was
contracted to the drug company to help
raise awareness about that condition and
so he went on Oprah and I'm one of the
opening lines I stand corrected on this
too but I'm pretty sure I've seen him
say this one of the opening lines was
I've always been a shy person and if it
wasn't Oprah it was one of the other big
television big television programs but
perhaps it was just a coincidence that
Ricky said that but I think it was his
comments were part of a very deliberate
strategy to blur the boundaries between
shyness and psychiatric illness in order
to make all all of us patients because
who among us isn't shy isn't fearful of
public speaking and and and doesn't
occasionally suffer those anxieties so
so so let's leave that when I move on to
the next great example and that is PMDD
I don't know how many of you know what
PMDD is there's a few frowns a few nods
PMDD is probably one of the most
controversial conditions in this book
most of the other conditions high blood
pressure high cholesterol there's not a
lot of controversy about them PMDD
stands for premenstrual dysphoric
disorder and it is one of the most
controversial because there are many
researchers in that field who say this
simply doesn't exist as a condition and
there are other researchers who say it
does and essentially what we're talking
about is premenstrual tension
premenstrual symptoms which familiar to
all the women in the audience and many
of the men as well
that wasn't meant to get a laugh but I'm
glad it glad it did because we need a
break from all the earnestness from time
to time
I'm glad the sound recordist has now
happy at least so so PMDD so what
happened with PMDD where did that come
from
you know which rock did that call out
from under well well it's actually an
interesting story well I think it's
interesting probably a few other people
do but I do and I've told it in one of
the chapters here there are a small
group of people on a committee that that
work with the DSM the DSM the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual diseases I think
the psychiatric Bible there were people
on a committee there who were determined
to argue for many years that PMDD was a
genuine disease on in its own right
sadly though that committee was riven
with conflict and controversy and the
committee itself couldn't agree on this
and so within the official psychiatrists
committee there was disagreement because
the evidence wasn't convincing that this
was a genuine disorder many people and
some of the people on that committee
argued this is just normal life women
have these issues and these symptoms at
this time every month some have severe
some have mild and so there was a big
debate about that
but what changed well what change was
that Lily the drug company was looking
at a very unfortunate scenario they were
looking at prozac coming off patent in
the 1990s and that's a very sad day
for Lily shareholders clearly because
Prozac as all as you all know what was a
big money spinner
firt for Lily so so what happened Lily
had quite an interest in finding new
markets for Prozac and one potential new
market was PMDD and so Lily sponsored a
roundtable of experts in the midst of
all this controversy about whether this
exists or doesn't exist as a condition
Lily walk in and sponsor a roundtable
Lilly representatives attend the
roundtable and the paper from the
roundtable is written up and published
in a journal a medical journal I must
say not one of the leading journals in
the world but but one of the journals
and that paper and that roundtable
becomes essentially the evidence the
legitimacy for this new disorder and and
in part on the basis of that the FDA
approved prozac for this new disorder
the problem is though even Lilly
realized that the trying to target
ordinary women with Prozac and saying
that their premenstrual problems are the
sign of a psychiatric illness is rather
difficult so what do they do as you all
know probably they repainted the pill
and they changed the name of the pill
they kept the chemical the same but they
changed the name and they called it
Seraphim and they marketed Seraphim for
PMDD and one of the classic images some
of you may have remember is the woman
trying to get her shopping cart out of a
out of a line of shopping carts and and
she was upset about that
clearly she she may have had a
psychiatric illness so sûreté I'm not
making this up it's all true sadly so of
course that was very controversial and
there was in fact the backlash as as
women's groups were some women's groups
and others were very concerned that
ordinary life was being portrayed as if
it was a symptom of medical illness this
is not to deny that some women suffer
severe problems at at at that time and
that and that there is not a legitimate
debate about how to diagnose and treat
this is not about trying to ignore or
downplay genuine scientific debate the
trouble is that Lily walks in with its
fat advertising budget and just starts
to skew the way we all think about this
problem and that's why I've written this
book to try and just remind everyone
that there are alternative ways of
thinking about this stuff and seeing it
and understanding it so the third
example let let's just finish off before
we get to some questions and hopefully
some some rigorous debate the third
example is female sexual dysfunction and
as I said before dr. Leonor T fir will
probably speak to this a little bit
later if there's time but but but let me
attempt to lay out what I see as one of
the freshest clearest examples of the
corporate-sponsored creation of disease
I'll just say that again the freshest
clearest example of the
corporate-sponsored creation of disease
because I think that's what we're
witnessing in real time as we speak as I
speak we we are we are living through
the creation of a new disease
and and what's fascinating as a
journalist is watching the way that
process is being contested by people
like Leonor and others in the audience
who are part of a a group a network of
people that are critiquing that
marketing and are offering alternative
understandings of female sexual
difficulty
so I choose this example with a lot of
thought in mind I know that it's rather
delicate for a man to be talking about
this stuff and I'll try to avoid any
crass jokes through it but which have
unfortunately unfortunately happened in
other of these launchers in Australia
but where Australia's a very crude
setting where as I know that the level
of sophistication here is much higher so
so even if there are unintentional
innuendos please ignore them so so just
briefly what happened with female sexual
dysfunction well from let's just start I
mean we've done it I don't know how far
we want to go back but let's start in
this sort of mid to late 1990s when it
was kind of clear that the
pharmaceutical industry particularly
fires that we were about to make a
killing out of erectile dysfunction it
was pretty clear by then that viagra was
gonna you know really really going to
change everything and and Pfizer as you
know have the headquarters just down the
road have made it have made a nice sum
out of Viagra again not to in any way
diminish the legitimate suffering of
people and the value that such a
medication can bring to them this book
is about the marketing it's not about
the drugs so much so so essentially
everyone was saying well look you know
the men that there's going to be a big
market there what about women and so the
key meetings through the late 90 min to
late 90s and onwards the key medical and
scientific meetings where this new
condition called female sexual
dysfunction was being
debated and defined and refined all of
them was sponsored by the drug industry
and not just sponsored but drug industry
representatives would attend and I've
now been to some of these meetings as
probably people here have and it's
unbelievable you walk in and you sit
down in the conference and you know as
one does particularly if you're a
journalist you start chatting to who's
next to you and lo and behold they're
from a drug company and it's like is
this a scientific meeting or is this a
marketing meeting it's very hard to know
these days and so one of the key
meetings my understanding is that that
that perhaps even half of the people at
the meeting we're representing drug
companies in some way and the other half
will researchers and this is a classic
example of the entanglement between the
pharmaceutical industry and the medical
profession and the Health Professions
generally and so the so then we we start
this sort of whole process it started
much earlier but let's just pick up the
story there so in the late 90s we we get
the first big consensus conference that
actually defines this condition medical
condition called female sexual
dysfunction correct me if I'm wrong 18
of the 19 authors have ties to drug
companies 18 of the 19 authors have ties
to drug companies I don't know who the
19th was probably it's probably a ring
in but but and so then the other
beautiful beautiful development in this
story is that in 1999 the Journal of the
American Medical Association comes out
with a paper with a straight face
suggesting that 43 percent of American
women suffer from this problem with a
straight face if a journal can have a
straight face it again I'm not making
this up I can't you know the things
referenced here and and again you know
we could go into detail about how they
arrived at that but essentially it's
it's a classic example of the ups and
downs of ordinary life the common sexual
difficulties that all of
experience being seen as signs of a
medical condition in order to build
markets for those who sell therapies and
an extrordinary example and one that's
being heavily critiqued by by many other
researchers in the in the sex field and
so just to spool forward and finish off
this example I wrote a piece in the
British Medical Journal a couple of
years ago called something like the
making of a diseased female sexual
dysfunction the making of a disease and
largely based on the work of Leonor t4
and others but essentially giving a kind
of a wrap up of the controversy about
how this new condition was being defined
and I should say that alongside of this
drug company sponsored process there was
another process that Leonor and others
were running feminists and other
researchers were getting together and
saying maybe there's a different way of
conceptualizing female sexual
difficulties maybe there's a different
way of solving them and a different way
of understanding them and they were
running conferences and and funding
their own educational processes and so
on and and and also critiquing drug
company involvement in this definition
over here and and it's that clash that
really is the central drama of the final
chapter of selling sickness but so just
to just to finish off my BMJ article
came out in 2003 it's probably one of
the only things that I've ever done
that's been noticed by anyone and that
was very exciting to be noticed around
the world and it got media attention
around the world within about a week an
email turns up in the entry of various
women's health groups around the world
consumer groups patient advocacy groups
around the world and the email was from
a small PR house in London suggesting
that these women's groups might like to
be involved in a campaign to counter my
BMJ article which was interesting
so one of these women's groups kindly
forwarded me the email which was nice so
I rang up the woman in London who was at
the PR house and said hello I'm Ramona
Han blah blah you know what's all this
about trying to counter my article oh no
no no we're not involved in anything
like that and I said well I've got the
email in front of me oh well yes maybe
we are involved in that you know I
forgot and then and anyway to cut a long
story short I wanted to know of course
who was the client which company was
involved in this clearly it's a little
PR House doesn't or big PR house doesn't
operate on its own it has a client has a
corporate client and she wouldn't say
and she in fact said explicitly it was a
secret it was a secret who their client
was and so through the tenacity and
temerity of some other journalists we
discovered that Pfizer was the client
and so within a week or two of an
article being published in one of the
best British with the best medical
journals in the world
we had an attempt to mount what
essentially is a fake grassroots
campaign to critique that and I think
the whole campaign fizzled because I
wrote about this again in the BMJ but
when I approached Pfizer one of the most
scary things was when I approached
Pfizer about this and said and wrote
them an email saying something along the
lines of did you organize a secret
campaign to counter the BMJ using
women's groups around the world the
answer was yes we did and what we did
was unremarkable and that that was a
lovely email back from them it was a
rare moment of candor and it was and it
was chilling in fact so let's let's just
finish off that example and because I
think we're running out of time and I'd
love to have some discussion so let's
just wrap up what what do we do about
all this I'm sorry I painted a sort of
bleak picture but but in fact lots is
happening
part of the problem here as I identified
earlier was this entanglement between
the medical profession and the
pharmaceutical industry and there are
real steps going on around the world to
disentangle including in this country
and and some examples from you from this
town there's a group here called no free
lunch it's a small group they use humor
what a great weapon that is they use
humor and they are currently running a
pen amnesty so if you're a family
physician out there in an Americans
prescribing land you can send in your
drug company pink as part of the pen
amnesty and and clean you clean your
conscience up that's right no questions
asked yet no name no names involved but
no free lunch is a serious organization
and it's serious about promoting some
disentanglement honor honor on a bigger
level you have the American Medical
Students Association 50,000 strong
American Medical Students Association
who have a policy of being farm free
that doesn't mean they don't like drugs
nothing could be further from the truth
they will go on to prescribe drugs to
people who need them for the rest of
their working lives safe efficacious
drugs that extend life and ameliorate
suffering but what that organization has
said is that they will not take money
from the drug industry so the American
medical students associate association
unlike almost every other professional
medical group in this country doesn't
take any money from drug companies it
encourages its members not to go on drug
company funded junkets not to work as
paid speakers to drug companies and they
are the doctors and physicians of
tomorrow and that strikes me as as one
example of this tentative step towards
towards disentanglement but I think
what's really needed and we're really
not there yet
our new structures for defining what is
illness and what is health because the
current panels that do this for us are
riddled with conflicts of interest and
perhaps may not deserve our trust and
that's going very far and I'm hopefully
going to be exposed to some criticism
for saying that but I think it's time
that these panels that are real with
conflicts of interests to take a step
back and have a look at themselves the
collector panel that put together the
most recent cholesterol guidelines eight
of the nine members that oversaw that
process have multiple ties to drug
companies eight of the nine and and and
some consumer groups are calling for
that situation to change and it may well
be time to change so um I'm sorry to go
out on such a such a serious note but
but that's really it from me I'd love to
I'd love to have some questions and some
criticism and and let's do that there's
a lot of questions here thank you
[Applause]
thank you my doctor says I need to take
a cholesterol drug or a blood pressure
drug how do I know that I'm in the
proper class versus outside the medical
border that that's a terrible question
because it's exactly the question that I
can't answer and and that is you know
I'm afraid to say that's the next book
that that you know what what you're
asking what to individual people do
about this in their daily interactions
with their health professionals and I've
got to say I don't know because that is
the scariest thing here and I actually
say in the in the in the end of this
book if your doctor offers you a label
is what you're saying I think it's time
that we were very skeptical skeptical I
think it's time we were skeptical about
accepting that label and I think you
need to talk to your loved ones and your
friends other health professionals read
as much of the literature as possible
that's that's a non-answer I'm sorry but
but you've really raised a big one so
just let me just go to that one okay
just stick on the red here
I'd agree that you shouldn't take drugs
unless you really need them they're all
bad for the liver but you give the
impression that wait but wait until a
disease is there don't you believe in
prevention with nutrition and variant
testing for allergies and stuff like
that and a couple of other things don't
you believe that ad D exists and where
can we you mean if we can go to one of
these American medical students in the
Association that they would give us a
fair shake not to tell us oh you gotta
go get operated on right away I think
that the the book in no way denies the
existence of these conditions
let me say that the book also suggests
that far from not supporting prevention
the book argues that the pharmaceutical
marketing is perverting our
understanding of prevention so more and
more when we think of prevention we
think of taking a drug to prevent future
illness and for some people that's
valuable for others at very low risk the
long-term benefits of the preventive
medicine are very modest and may not
outweigh the harms and so this is a
complex question you raise but an
important one well I think probably
because there students at this stage you
probably won't be seeing them but but
sooner or later you will be seeing them
and and you know they'll kind of diffuse
into the community I mean you're welcome
you know you're welcome to go and talk
to them about their policy and how that
you know what the pros and cons of that
are thank you yeah I'm not sure if
they'll give you that at this point here
in the blue you know I agree with a lot
of what you say it's also not just drug
companies as well there are radiological
companies that are looking to sell their
CT scanners and their virtual
colonoscopy machines it's sort of the
business of medicine and pharmaceutical
the device manufacturers and as people
might know there is a currently a
federal probe of the relationship
between surgeons and device
manufacturers and that will be very
interesting to see how that goes
question right at the back in the white
over there
in terms of the psychological disorders
for which people prescribe drugs
nowadays I think you're talking about
part of a much broader and deeper trend
in the culture which is this biological
definition of the mind it's almost as if
we're living in this vast denial
mechanism where the psyche has been
totally overridden by this kind of
collective fantasy that everything is a
biological disorder so I think it's
really something very very strange going
on part of it is the marketing it but
part of it is almost a collective denial
of the psyche that's very interesting
and in fact one of the things I argue in
the book is that there's this
interesting contradiction at the same
time an attempt to narrow the
understanding of the causes of illness
but but but broaden the numbers who
suffer from it but you're absolutely
right there's a real narrowing process
we've got it where's where's the mic
just here quickly yeah about 50 60 years
ago when I had difficulty problems of
adjustment I was recommended to go to a
psychiatrist so I know the experience of
working with a psychiatrist presently I
have so much judgment problems I get too
excited about things that are wrong and
referred to a psychiatrist and he wants
to give me pills all the time
well these pills they keep me away they
keep me awake well then take these pills
they'll put you to sleep now he's in the
pill business no you're aware of that
I'm sure yeah I mean I'm a journalist
sadly so I can't really comment but
right over here thank you
cells rather than marketing but I think
it's an important point this this was in
Time magazine recommending Crestor and
which is supposed to get your high
cholesterol down well Public Citizen is
a very good nonprofit organization and
they said for two years they've been
trying to get Cresta off the market
because it does kidney damage and it's
the most dangerous fad and drug out
there
well in terms of maybe fixing this
problem to some extent they also had an
article reform sought to fix an ailing
FDA and senators Charles Grassley and
Christopher Dodd that's of Iowa and
Connecticut are would create a new drug
safety office within the FDA with
substantial funding relative
independence and broad powers and
there's another measure called the fair
access to clinical trials the fact Act
which would create a publicly accessible
databank that would include detailed
results of all clinical drug trials
because at present many of these results
are not made public so I think we could
at least support these efforts because
if they have true independence we can
get some of the worst drugs off the mark
I think I think this Ron I think the
FDA's perhaps has reached its nadir if I
can use that term I'm not sure how you
pronounce it in this country and and
maybe it's on this upswing so you're
absolutely right just before we go on is
it can we rather than all agree is there
anyone who wants to criticize take issue
with some of the points we've got two
people here first of all of the
medicalization of life I think that the
medicalization of a lot of conditions is
a good thing
because why deny the people the benefits
of possible medical help and medical
approaches to problems that they could
there has to be the right medicalization
in the past a lot of things were
medicalised unnecessarily women were
called hysterical take Carter's little
little liver pills to make your children
regular and said or the wrong thing it's
a it's a matter of making the things
medicalised but really ought to be like
for example arthritis is now medicalized
instead of just being considered the
normal pain of being of old age and
attempts are made to find drugs and
approaches to help it with regard to to
the criticism of drugs while the
criticism of drugs
valid many people are eating the wrong
food or the wrong amounts of food yet no
one is saying that people shouldn't stop
eating or that there shouldn't be a food
industry we have to learn which drugs
are genuinely helpful to our health and
which are not and you need an informed
consumer and informed representatives of
consumers to inform them unfortunately
I've heard for a long time that there
should be an informed patient and the
patient shouldn't simply take every drug
that the doctor suggests he taking so
for patients one of the ways in which
patients do get informed is through
medical advertising and even though it's
once the medical advertising is
one-sided people know that these are
advertisements and most people at least
Westsiders known to to discount
advertising and it might lead them to
look for more information elsewhere from
better sources have more comments to
make but for the time being thank you
thank you very much just down the back
there they they got here just if you
want to wait for mine thank you not
quite sure what the reference to West
Side is is but we'll check later
while we're on the Upper West Side okay
thank you sorry I think that it's very
important to acknowledge that the idea
of medicating healthy people although a
lot of you've been stressing the idea
that this is coming from the medical
from the pharmaceutical industry for the
purpose of marketing and making profits
you also have to acknowledge that a lot
of it comes from biomedical research and
a lot of it is very legitimate fifty
years ago we didn't think obesity was a
as a risk factor for anything now we
know it's a serious respect
we didn't think high cholesterol we
didn't know that high blood pressure was
a serious risk factor for disease these
are all symptoms in healthy people and
in fact I think that one of the great
struggles in modern medical and
biomedical research is the
acknowledgment of prevention as a better
tool than therapy for dealing with
complex modern diseases such as cancer
heart disease diabetes etc this is
generally shared by many people in the
biomedical research community and I
think everything you're saying is
correct in terms of the pharmaceutical
company and marketing but the danger
that I'm worried about is relating what
the other gentleman said it said about
prevention you have to be very careful i
I'm sure you agree with everything I'm
saying you have to be very careful that
you distinguish perhaps the evil part of
marketing by pharmaceutical companies
from the very very important part of
convincing people that they need to take
sometimes medicine sometimes not but
they need to do something about
preventing future illnesses
based on current symptom ology this is a
very very interesting point and it's
this this question about when you want
to put out preventative messages and
health promotional messages to what
extent to do you see your future risks
as part of a medical condition or not
and to what extent do your future risks
become the mode of
to take preventive steps that could
include medicines or not and it's a
fascinating debate and there's a
question right at the back right at the
back there I'd like to bring up a
counter example but and it took up a bit
okay okay a counter example in the sense
of a medical condition that's under
emphasize and that's a hospital
engendered infection in the general role
of infectious disease because the
general mood of all of this is yes we
need to care about things that are
statins and so on all the stuff other
people were bringing up it's not exactly
the actual condition in the society and
one of the reasons that you know that
the hospitals for instance don't reveal
the amount of hospital and gendered
infection and pretend that the
antibiotics and sanitation conditions
work and all that so it's relatively
under emphasized thank you but I think
through the same kind of process thank
you right at the front here there's a
lady here and if that if we could get
some price control of the exorbitant
prices that are being charged for drugs
in which people may be spending hundreds
of dollars every month on the drugs that
are provided that if there was some
control of that there may be the
incentive to keep pushing the drugs
would be lessened sure you look the
whole issue of pricing is a it's a
touchy and controversial and in this
country I know but just just be but but
the book doesn't essentially address
that just before we go on Leonor do you
want to add anything quickly on the
female sexual dysfunction issue just
quickly there's not a lot of
investigative health journalism going on
I mean in New York the health journalism
that we get in the media for example
Jane Brody is not investigative health
journalism it's largely promotional and
marketing health journalism and to have
you know there's few and people like
gray are a few
and far between and it's it's just
something that I think we want to
support as much as possible to get more
investigative generally when is the last
time there was some big expose in The
Daily News or in the New York Times
there actually have been exposes
recently in the Seattle
post-intelligencer you know there was
something terrific down south someplace
wherever that is but you know the in the
knight-ridder the knight-ridder i don't
know anything about journalism he
doesn't know anything about medicine so
this is a great great team here but you
know stories about off-label prescribing
you know we don't have investigative
journalists in the health and science
world in New York and I really think
that's that's something we ought to do
something about thank you but you I mean
just to just to sort of add you know in
defense of journalism here I there's a
reporter at the LA Times called David
Willman who's whose stories are
literally changing America his
investigations of conflicts of interest
at the LA at the conflicts of interest
at the FDA and at the NIH are sparking
genuine public policy reactions and so
even Congress which is also known for
its conflicts of interest even Congress
has has moved to try and clean up both
the FDA and the NIH in terms of the
conflicts of interest at those
institutions so this is David Willman in
the LA Times I mean he's he's just one
but there are there are other great
journalists around and and occasionally
they have an effect there's a lot of
questions still just down at there and
then we'll come down here first I
congratulate you on writing what you're
writing as I listen to this whole thing
what what I really think you're talking
about is systemic and goes across not
just the medical field but it's kind of
a lack of ethics in virtually all fields
society today and just a quick example
might be the food industry so for
example there's a Skippy peanut butter
that came out with a low-fat peanut
butter and then when you look it's
they call it a spread and when you look
at the ingredients what they've added is
trans fatty acids to make it but is
spread in Pop scuse me in politics we
know we know what goes on we know the
kinds of lies so so I'm wondering if you
could tie in I don't mean here but if
people that are interested journalists
and consumers could tie in all the
special interests that are dealing
without ethics to really trick and fool
the consumers and if there might not be
more power by getting all those special
interest groups under one umbrella and
all the people that are interested in
exposing them thank you just down the
front there's a couple of questions here
but just while you're repoing the my and
there's an organization in Washington
called the Center for Science in the
Public Interest
and if I've got the name right and that
Center has done a lot of work along the
lines that you're talking about and is
essentially looking at the way in which
science is often distorted in the
interests of whoever is funding that
science and and I think they among other
groups are drawing connections across
different sectors but so far my work has
been specifically in the health and
medical area thank you for wetting the
book I I come from what they call the
third world country and I spend more
time with the work that I do I spent a
lot of time with women from this country
and I see more hopelessness in American
women than in women in my country and
it's all about fear I feel that American
women don't know their power because
they are being exploited and they don't
even know it and that angers the hell
out of me and I'm so happy to see
someone we're writing it down thank you
no thank you thank you very much
there's something that I think needs to
be added to this discussion and that's
the context out of which this problem
comes namely the purpose for which
corporations are chartered to serve 300
of the fortune 500 corporations are
chartered in the state of Delaware their
purpose is to maximize profit for
stockholders there are some states and
which the purpose is to maximize the
interest of all stakeholders if we could
move in that direction maybe even with
federal chartering I think a lot of the
problems we have would diminish I think
it's interesting it's it's outside my
area I think we're probably gonna have
to wrap up here I'm sorry but I think
we're um we've reached our limit
I mean I'm available to sign and to talk
and there are some books in this
bookstore to self which is which is
after a wife made the big trip from
Australia but I also all all cynicism
aside really appreciate you all coming
if you want to berate me afterwards
please do but I really appreciate that
this is a great debate I'm very very
touched that you all came and the next
book will be